* Trommelwirbel *
Die Ecole Hoteliere de Lausanne
gehört
zu den renommiertesten Handelsschulen
für die Hotelindustrie.
2'800 Studenten aus über 110 Nationen
streben an der EHL nach Exzellenz,
Können und Selbstbewusstsein.
Wir begleiten drei Studenten
im Vorbereitungsjahr
und zwei am Ende ihres Studiums.
Alexandre Charlaix, 18 Jahre alt.
Mit seiner Matura in der Tasche
geht er in das Vorbereitungsjahr.
Emma Pittet ist 21, wurde
in der Genferseeregion geboren
und beginnt ihr Studium
an dieser internationalen Schule.
Genau wie Alexandre Attia,
19 Jahre alt.
Der Sohn eines Hoteliers geht mit
Selbstvertrauen ins erste Semester.
Annina von Falkenstein.
Mit 21 beginnt sie
ihr vorletztes Studienjahr.
Die junge Baslerin strebt
nach nichts weniger als Exzellenz.
Afrim Beqa, 27,
startet sein letztes Semester.
Der energetische Afrim möchte
selbstständiger Unternehmer werden.
Letztes Mal in der Hotelfachschule:
Alexandres Verhalten
ist nicht angemessen.
Leider sind Ihre Noten tief,
weil Ihr Verhalten
den Werten der Schule
überhaupt nicht entspricht.
Was ist denn mit deiner Tür passiert?
Ich kam rein, war genervt und
habe ein bisschen Dampf abgelassen.
Aber in der Praxis gibt er sich Mühe.
D-Day für Afrim und sein Team:
Sie stellen ihr Diplomprojekt
Kunden und Jury vor.
Sie haben mit Erfolg bestanden!
* Applaus *
Vier erfolgreiche Schuljahre:
Das wird mit der Familie
und mit Würde gefeiert.
* Jubel *
(Alle) Sante!
Annina ist weit weg vom Ball,
in Budapest.
Vor vier Tagen habe ich
meine letzten Prüfungen geschrieben.
Ich denke, es ist eher gut gelaufen.
Kurzer Moment der Entspannung
mit ihrer Kollegin und Freundin.
Aber sie sind nicht
als Touristen hier,
sie arbeiten als Hostessen
an einer internationalen Konferenz.
Emma tut alles,
um ihre Schulter zu entlasten.
Ich habe viel Physiotherapie ge-
macht, Übungen für die Halsmuskeln,
so konnte ich meine Schulter
ein wenig stabilisieren.
Aber seither
habe ich zu wenig trainiert.
Alex hat die lange Liste
der Küchenunfälle noch erweitert.
Passiert so was oft?
Sehr, sehr häufig.
Am Ende des Semesters beginnt Emma
mit dem Gourmet-Kochworkshop.
Sie freut sich
auf den berühmten Messerkoffer,
der allen Studierenden
übergeben wird.
Wir kommen dem Semesterende näher,
bald beginnt unser Praktikum.
Ich freue mich darauf.
Wir kennen uns jetzt besser aus
in der Küche.
Es ist einfacher,
sich wieder zu erholen.
(Frau) Schau, ich schneide so.
Ich auch.
Es ist ziemlich schwierig,
man muss die Finger richtig halten.
Das macht mir Angst.
In der Wiege der Sinne,
dem Gourmet-Saal der Schule,
führt Alex mit seinem Chef
eine Generalprobe durch.
Also, das Menü Sensibilite, genau,
wollen Sie die Option mit Käse?
Also, beim Menü Sensibilite
beginnen wir mit der Vorspeise.
Was wünschen Sie zur Vorspeise,
Madame?
Ich nehme eine Entenleber
und für den Hauptgang ...
Kann ich die Entenbrust
vom Menü Evanescence bekommen?
Alles, was im Menü Sensibilite ist,
finden Sie hier, sonst können wi...
Sagen Sie genau das,
was ich Ihnen vorher gesagt habe:
Madame,
es gibt zwei Menüs zur Auswahl,
die man nicht kombinieren kann.
Okay,
dann nehme ich das Schweinekotelett.
Gut, Schweinekotelett.
Hätten Sie gerne Käse dazu?
Genau, jetzt sind Sie der Leader.
Hätten Sie gerne Käse? Nein, danke.
Gut, Madame. Und als Dessert?
Schaue ich später,
ich muss mich noch entscheiden.
Für Ihren Komfort empfiehlt Ihnen
das Team ... - Nicht das Team. Wir.
Wir empfehlen Ihnen,
das Dessert schon zu bestellen.
Im Voraus. - Im Voraus.
- Für Ihren Komfort.
Für Ihren Komfort
empfehlen wir Ihnen,
das Dessert
schon im Voraus zu bestellen.
Genau, super,
also ich nehme das Souffle.
Geht klar.
- Man sagt nicht "geht klar".
Verzeihung. - Danke, Madame. Jetzt
wiederholen Sie die Bestellung!
Die Entenleber zur Vorspeise,
das Schweinekotelett als Hauptgang
und zum Dessert noch das Souffle.
- Sehr gut.
Die Theorie ist jetzt fertig, Praxis
in 2 Min., viel Glück. - Danke.
Stress bringt nichts,
wir geben einfach unser Bestes.
Ich versuche,
mich an alles zu erinnern.
Ich konzentriere mich
auf den Moment.
* Entspannte jazzige Klänge *
Annina besucht
einen der letzten Kurse
ihrer englischsprachigen
Schulsektion: digitales Marketing.
Gibt es Leute unter Ihnen,
die auf sozialen Netzwerken
Influencern folgen?
Die Influencer, das sind diejenigen,
die neue Trends verbreiten.
Reisen, Essen, Gesundheit
und Wellness, Mode, Schönheit.
Das sind die fünf Hauptbereiche.
Wenn Sie also ein Hotel mit Spa,
Fitnesscenter und Yogastudio haben,
sind diese Dinge sehr wichtig.
Gute Influencer können das,
was sie machen,
auf spektakuläre Weise
vervielfachen. Aber Vorsicht:
Follower
kann man ganz leicht kaufen.
Ein Hotel mit vielen Followern
beeindruckt, man denkt, das ist gut.
Aber wenn man auf die Fotos klickt,
sieht man:
Da gibt es nicht viele Likes
und kein echtes Engagement.
Das sind keine Influencer,
sondern Leute,
die nur profitieren wollen
von Gratisnächten.
* Entspannte jazzige Klänge *
Das Gourmet-Restaurant
empfängt seine ersten Kunden.
Bonjour, je m'appelle Alexandre,
je viens de Geneve ...
Machen Sie das jetzt so,
wie Sie es gelernt haben.
Viel Glück!
Grosse Premiere für Alex,
der um jeden Preis
seine Nervosität verbergen muss.
Guten Tag,
ich begrüsse Sie ganz herzlich.
Mein Name ist Alexandre,
ich komme aus Genf
und ich werde Sie heute bedienen.
Lassen Sie mich
Ihnen das Menü präsentieren!
Heute haben wir das Menü Evanescence
und das Menü Sensibilite.
Ich lasse Sie wählen
und komme gleich wieder.
Super, merci!
- Merci a vous.
Das ist gut. Achten wir noch
auf die Feinheiten der Präsentation!
Bitte beachten Sie, dass Sie nicht
alles gleichzeitig machen.
Sie können nicht erklären,
während Sie die Menüs austeilen,
sonst wird Ihnen nicht zugehört.
Wenn mir das Menü
zum Lesen gegeben wird,
fokussiere ich nicht mehr auf das,
was Sie sagen.
Ohne Selbstvertrauen
versaut man es schnell.
Stosszeit hinter den Kulissen.
Emma ist für das Anrichten der Teller
zuständig.
(Mann) Noch etwas Pfeffer drauf.
(Mann) Die Teller
zur Kontrolle rüberschieben.
* Energiegeladene Musik *
* Verspielte jazzige Klänge *
Merci.
- Merci, Monsieur.
Die Herde laufen auf Hochtouren.
In der Cafeteria werden sieben
verschiedene Gerichte angeboten,
täglich neue Spezialitäten.
Und es gibt vier weitere Orte
für Take-away, Sandwiches, Salate
oder Backwaren und das Gourmetlokal.
Ich möchte ja beruflich eher
in Richtung Human Resources gehen,
wenn ich mit der Schule hier
fertig bin.
Es ist nicht so, dass ich dort sitze
und denke, das geht mich nichts an.
Denn gerade auch
im Bereich Human Resources
muss man ein gewisses Marketing
betreiben.
Ich möchte ja gute Leute finden,
die bei mir arbeiten möchten.
Um die guten Leute anzuziehen,
müssen sie wissen,
warum ich ein guter Arbeitgeber bin,
der bessere als das Hotel XY,
das zwei Strassen weiter ist.
Es hilft mir sehr, die Marketing-
Perspektive genauer zu betrachten.
Tu vas aller la.
- Okay.
Nach dem Mittagsansturm
müssen die Küchen gereinigt werden.
Der Workshop nennt sich Stewarding.
Und, wie läuft's beim Stewarding?
Ganz locker,
man poliert ein bisschen die Geräte.
Man muss einfach putzen,
dafür braucht man ja
nicht viel im Kopf.
Es dauert schon ziemlich lange, aber
die Leute hier sind wenigstens nett.
Geht es gut mit Alexandre?
Alexandre arbeitet sehr gut.
Super cool. Er ist gross und stark.
Aber Alex,
das hier ist ja noch schmutzig.
Mehr Papier.
Schau, so macht man das!
Nun glänzt es.
Was für eine Technik.
Nur noch zwei Tage, dann ist Schluss
mit diesen Schuhen und Hosen.
Letzte Woche
gab ich schon die Kochhaube ab.
Und nächste Woche?
Bar-Service, voll easy.
Keine Absicht, Chef.
Arbeiten, der Kollegin helfen,
keine Dummheiten!
Alles klar.
Nicht rumspielen!
- Ich hab's nicht extra gemacht.
Nicht extra?
Putzt die Griffe!
Wenn Sie fertig sind, putzen Sie
die Ablage, die Saucenflecken.
Ich weiss, das hat man mir
gestern schon gesagt.
Ich warte nur noch drauf,
bis es endlich fertig ist.
Ich bin am Ende.
Mir bleiben
nur noch fünf Arbeitstage.
Das waren
sechs sehr intensive Monate,
ausserhalb der Kurse
mussten wir nicht lernen.
Es gab Tage
mit 11 oder 12 Std. Arbeit.
Wir sind alle fix und fertig
und freuen uns auf die professio-
nelle Umgebung im Praktikum.
Vor dem grossen Sprung
auf den Arbeitsmarkt
kümmert sich Afrim um seine
Studienabschlussreise nach Thailand.
Eine langfristige Mission
zusammen mit den anderen Mitgliedern
des Komitees, die sich
für dieses Abenteuer engagieren.
Wir arbeiten
schon seit einem Jahr daran.
Es ist nicht immer einfach.
Manchmal muss man rund 200 Leute
über verschiedene Länder hinweg
koordinieren.
Alles ist all inclusive,
auch der Alkohol.
So können die Leute trinken,
wann sie wollen.
Auch das Essen und die Aktivitäten
sind all inclusive, alle Transporte.
Man geht nach Thailand
für 1'700 Fr. pro Person.
Das ist wirklich nicht schlecht,
all inclusive für zehn Tage.
Das ist ein Spezialangebot
extra für uns,
das gibt's nicht im Reisebüro.
Wir haben einige Sponsoren,
die uns Produkte zugeschickt haben,
damit wir
kleine Tüten machen können.
Wir sind froh, den Teilnehmern
ein Geschenk machen zu können.
Heute bereiten wir alles vor:
Apres soleil, Sonnencreme,
für die Mädchen auch noch
wasserfesten Lippenstift.
Super cool!
* Entspannte jazzige Klänge *
Emma kommt frühmorgens in Genf an.
Sie hat einen freien Tag bekommen
für Vorstellungsgespräche,
in der Hoffnung, das
bestmögliche Praktikum zu erhalten.
Ich habe jetzt
zwei Bewerbungsgespräche,
eines in Genf und eines in Lausanne,
für Swiss Wine,
das ist ein neues Hotel.
Wie viele Gespräche hast du?
Fünf. Zwei hatte ich schon, ich bin
also nicht mehr ganz so aufgeregt.
Nicht leicht zu finden,
denn die Konkurrenz schläft nicht.
Im Bus bereitet sich Emma mental vor.
Ich habe jetzt ein Gespräch
mit dem Personaldienst
und dann mit dem Chef der Rezeption.
Der Personaldienst wird mir
wahrscheinlich mehr mathematische
und logische Fragen stellen.
Da geht es eher um Gedächtnistests.
Das Telefon
hat sie auf stumm gestellt.
So geht Emma zu ihren potenziellen
zukünftigen Arbeitgebern.
Ein Interview,
dem wir nicht beiwohnen konnten.
Etwas später am Morgen
kommt auch Alexandre in Genf an.
Obwohl er sehr spät dran ist,
um ein Job-Interview zu bekommen,
konnte er vom Netzwerk seines Vaters
profitieren,
der in der Hotelwelt
viel Einfluss hat.
Dank ihm hat Alexandre einen Termin
in einem berühmten
Genfer Hotel-Palast bekommen.
Es ist ein sehr schönes Hotel hier,
für mich das schönste in Genf.
Ich hoffe, ich werde hier
mein Praktikum absolvieren.
Ich hoffe, dass alles gut läuft.
Ich weiss nicht,
was schiefgehen könnte.
Bonjour, Monsieur Attia, bienvenu.
- Bonjour, merci.
Die Personalmanagerin Caroline Bühler
bietet ihm sogar
verschiedene Möglichkeiten an.
Wären Sie bereit,
ein Basispraktikum zu absolvieren?
Ich weiss nicht,
ob Roomservice Ihnen entspricht.
Würden Sie lieber in die Küche?
Ja, sehr gerne.
Ich zeige Ihnen das Restaurant.
Bonjour.
- Bonjour.
Hier sind die zwei Speisesäle.
Jetzt zeige ich Ihnen die Küche,
damit Sie einen Eindruck bekommen.
Frau Bühler bringt Alexandre
zum Leiter des Restaurants.
Ich komme später wieder.
In einem anderen
grossen Genfer Etablissement
hat auch Emma
den Personalmanager getroffen.
Sie haben sich
nach meinen Erfahrungen erkundigt,
warum die EHL,
warum das InterContinental.
Dann fragten sie auf Englisch
nach meinen Stärken,
nach meinen Arbeitserfahrungen
und wie ich auf gewisse Situationen
reagieren würde.
Es ist sehr gut gelaufen.
Auch wenn es in Genf ist,
würde ich gerne hier arbeiten,
denn ich könnte viel lernen.
Hoffnungsvoll
kehrt sie nach Lausanne zurück,
zu ihrem zweiten Treffen des Tages.
Nun ist Alexandre an der Reihe,
sein Bestes zu zeigen.
Mit seinem gewohnten Auftreten
wird er Mr. Perfect spielen -
in aller Demut, aber
unter allen Umständen selbstsicher.
Hatten Sie jemals in Ihrer Karriere
Probleme mit Regeln?
Generell mit Regeln? Nein.
Hatten Sie jemals Probleme
mit der Equipe?
Mit der Equipe nie.
Was ist ihr Lieblingswein?
Ich bin kein grosser Weintrinker,
kein Kenner.
Am liebsten trinke ich Weisswein.
Stilrichtung?
Das kann ich nicht sagen.
- Käse?
Keine Ahnung,
das ist ich nicht mein Gebiet.
Haben Sie unser Menü gelesen?
Nein, weil ich nicht wusste,
welche Stellung ich bekomme.
Merci beaucoup.
- Je vous remercie.
Es ist super gelaufen, ich habe
eine klare Jobbeschreibung erhalten.
Es hat mich überzeugt. Ich hoffe,
ich kann hier mein Praktikum machen.
Die Aussicht ist wunderschön,
die Berge, der See
und die Genfer Fontäne.
* Entspannte Musik *
Auf Afrim und die 200 Absolventen
warten ganz andere Aussichten.
Landung
auf der All-Inclusive-Insel.
Machen wir ein Rennen?
Nach monatelanger Vorbereitung
und stundenlangem Reisen
ist es nun an der Zeit zu prüfen,
ob Coconut Island
ihre Erwartungen erfüllt.
Das sieht super aus.
Schau dir die Aussicht an!
Ich hoffe, das Becken hat 28 °C,
sonst gibt's Ärger.
* Entspannte Musik *
Anninas Vater besucht seine Tochter.
Die EHL ist eine Managementschule.
Hat Annina auch punkto Kochen
etwas dazugelernt?
Man muss so anfangen:
Als ich zum ersten Mal dachte,
ich koche mir eine Bouillon,
ist die Bouillon angebrannt.
Das ist eigentlich unmöglich,
weil es ein Pulver ist,
das sich
im kochenden Wasser auflöst.
Ich bin also wirklich als Null
im Kochen an die Schule gekommen.
Dadurch, dass ich koordinations-
technisch nicht völlig unbegabt bin,
habe ich das ganze Schnippeln ohne
namhaften Fingerverlust überstanden.
Und man lernt, wie man helfen kann,
wie man sich nützlich macht.
Guten Appetit.
- Euch auch, danke schön.
Annina ist ambitioniert, ihr Ziel:
ein Abschluss mit High Honours,
einer Ehrenerwähnung.
Es ist jetzt realistischer,
als es auch schon war.
Entsprechend versuche ich natürlich,
den entsprechenden Schnitt zu haben.
Aber es kommt auch darauf an,
wie die nächsten Wochen laufen.
Von zu Hause
habe ich ja keinen Druck.
* Lachen *
Wenn Druck da ist,
dann von mir selbst.
Ich halte meine Ziele mal hoch
und schaue,
wie nahe ich ihnen
tatsächlich komme.
Wird Annina die Bestnoten erreichen?
* Entspannte elektronische Klänge *
Letzter Tag des Semesters.
Emma hat gerade erfahren, dass sie
in Genf ein Praktikum bekommt.
Nächste Woche
beginne ich mein Praktikum.
Ich freue mich,
das wird eine tolle Erfahrung.
Die sechs Monate Schule waren super.
Ich bin ein wenig traurig,
aufzuhören,
aber ich freue mich auf das Neue.
Letzte Unbekannte:
die Resultate ihrer Prüfungen.
Ich hoffe, ich habe alle bestanden.
Man weiss es nie,
denn die Sozialkompetenznoten
sind schwierig einzuschätzen.
Aber im Grossen und Ganzen habe ich
nur positive Rückmeldungen erhalten.
Gut, denn die Nachprüfungen
kosten ja zusätzlich.
Ja, 300 Fr. Und wenn du fehlst,
verlierst du noch Punkte.
Ausser man hat
eine ärztliche Entschuldigung.
300 für alle Prüfungen?
300 pro Prüfung.
Auch Alexandre zählt die Tage.
Wie erwartet hat er
sein Praktikum in Genf bekommen.
Ich beginne das Praktikum im März,
denn sie können mich
jetzt noch nicht beschäftigen.
Die Saison hat noch nicht begonnen,
und sie brauchen noch keinen
zusätzlichen Mitarbeiter.
Um 4 Uhr
gibt es eine Abschiedszeremonie.
Adieu, Vorbereitungsjahr!
Eine Erlösung für mich, ich warte
schon lange darauf, gehen zu können.
Die Schule ist fast leer,
weil alle Bachelor-Studenten
ihr Semester bereits beendet haben.
Alex wartet
auf die Abschlusszeremonie
und entdeckt,
wie flüchtig seine Finanzen sind.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass mir ein paar Franken fehlen,
ist aber nicht schlimm. Danke.
Ich denke gerade ...
Ich habe heute Mittag
noch 100 Fr. gehabt.
Aha!
Hallo, Mom!
Könntest du mir
mein Taschengeld überweisen?
Ich bin erstaunt, ich wusste nicht,
dass ich so wenig Geld
auf meinem Konto habe.
Meine Mutter
hat mir zwar Geld gegeben,
um es auf meine Karte zu laden, aber
das beunruhigt mich jetzt ein wenig.
20 Fr. pro Mahlzeit,
sprich 40 pro Tag,
sind dann 200 pro Woche,
das tut weh.
Ich musste meinen Lebensstil ändern.
Am Anfang findet man es super und
trinkt noch einen Smoothie oder so,
aber nun ist Schluss damit.
Auch er hat ein Praktikum in einem
renommierten Hotel in Genf ergattert.
Ich serviere dort dann im Cafe.
Ich muss anfangen,
die Karte zu lesen.
Gut, wenn ich schon
ein bisschen Bescheid weiss.
Am Anfang
habe ich drei Tage Ausbildung.
Weiss du, was du verdienst?
Ja, 2'179 brutto pro Monat.
Ganz okay,
ich kann ja zu Hause schlafen
und alles für mich behalten.
Ich werde mir einen Auspuff kaufen,
das wird richtig flutschen.
Es läuft aber nicht überall
wie geschmiert.
Monika ist für das Vorbereitungsjahr
verantwortlich und weiss das bestens.
In der Schweiz
verdienen die Schüler viel.
In Frankreich z.B.
verdienen Praktikanten
rund 440 Euro pro Monat.
Davon kann man
in Paris z.B. nicht leben.
Aber hier in der Schweiz verdienen
die Praktikanten im Gastgewerbe
und in der Hotellerie gemäss Gesetz
etwa 2'200 Fr. im Monat.
Und wenn man noch
bei den Eltern lebt,
ist das ein guter Lohn
für 18-jährige junge Leute.
* Entspannte jazzige Klänge *
Operation Umzug für Emma.
Sie muss
sechs Monate ihres Lebens einpacken.
Wie ist es für dich,
dein Zimmer zu verlassen?
Ich hatte Glück
mit meiner Zimmerkollegin.
Es ist traurig.
Ich werde meine Freundin vermissen
während diesen sechs Monaten.
Hier bist du den ganzen Tag
mit anderen Leuten zusammen
und abends im Zweierzimmer.
Es wird sicher guttun, auch mal
ein bisschen Privatsphäre zu haben.
Trotzdem werde ich
dieses Zimmer vermissen.
* Schrei *
Oh my god!
Der Campus kocht, die Schüler haben
bis zum nächsten Tag nur 8 Std. Zeit,
um ihre Zimmer zu räumen.
Ich habe alles.
Der Messerkoffer?
- Den nehme ich mit.
So viel wie diese Schule kostet ...
Sicher nehme ich den mit.
Hast du zu Hause
wieder mehr Privatsphäre?
Ja, ich vermisse mein Zuhause,
mein Doppelbett.
Der Luxus eines Doppelbetts,
ein eigenes Bad.
All das gibt es hier nicht.
Zeit für einen Apero.
Das Semesterende der Studierenden
im Vorbereitungsjahr.
Die Stunde
des grossen Auseinandergehens.
Alle brechen auf ins Praktikum,
einige ans andere Ende der Welt.
Und alle treffen sich für die
Auszeichnung der besten Equipe,
des Teams, das sich in allen
Bereichen am besten verhalten hat.
Man sagt, das Vorbereitungsjahr
sei leicht. War es leicht?
(Viele) Ja!
Das Lehrpersonal
hat ein herausragendes Team erkoren.
Ich verkünde es auf Französisch,
weil es
aus der französischen Sektion kommt.
* Jubel *
Wir gratulieren dem Team ...
L'equipe 4!
Auf Emmas Team
wartet ein VIP-Bereich.
Hier fliesst der Champagner
in Strömen.
* Jubel *
(Alle) Sante!
Letzte Momente, letzte Abschiede.
Sie werden sich
lange nicht wiedersehen,
und in diesen ersten sechs Monaten
haben sie Freundschaften geschmiedet.
Einige brechen bereits
zu fernen Horizonten auf,
andere wählen die Nähe.
Der Zwillingsbruder von Alex kommt,
um ihn abzuholen,
ihn und seinen Mitbewohner.
Das nimmst du mit.
Wir sind noch nicht fertig, ich habe
noch zwei volle Abfallsäcke.
Schau mal!
Was?
Das ist Loris, mein Zwillingsbruder.
Wie viele gibt's von euch?
Sind Sie froh,
Ihre Tochter wiederzusehen?
Klar doch. Abreise zu ihrem
Praktikum im InterContinental.
Sind Sie stolz?
Ja, sehr stolz,
dass sie es geschafft hat.
Ich bin mir
noch nicht 100%ig sicher.
Ich erhalte meine Resultate
erst am 14.
Bist du optimistisch?
- Ja.
* Jazzige Klänge *
Annina und ihre Gruppe
müssen das Studenten-Business-Projekt
vorbereiten:
ein Konzept für eine
Schweizer Grossbank. Ihre Aufgabe:
kommerzielle Lösungen zu finden,
um junge Menschen anzulocken.
Mobile Banking, einfaches Banking,
sympathisches Banking -
ein umfangreiches Programm.
Ein Glücksfall
für dieses Unternehmen,
dass die Studenten voller Feuer sind.
Sie haben einen Vertrag mit der
Schule und bezahlen dafür 10'000 Fr.
Und ihr bekommt nichts,
wenn das umgesetzt wird?
Nein, nur den Ruhm.
Oder auch nicht.
Ihre erste Kundenpräsentation
ist für den folgenden Montag geplant.
Und wer wird verantwortlich sein
für die Präsentation der Gruppe?
Es muss eine Person sein,
die keine Angst davor hat,
den Kunden gefallen zu wollen.
Ihnen zu zeigen,
dass alles gut läuft,
dass wir die Situation
vollkommen unter Kontrolle haben.
Vielleicht bin ich diese Person.
* Entspannte jazzige Musik *
In Phuket gehen Afrim und seine
Absolventengruppe auf den Markt.
Wir sind hier
auf dem Phuket-Thai-Markt.
Es ist der grösste Markt in Phuket.
Um sich
den ganzen Markt reinzuziehen,
braucht man locker 3-4 Std.
Es ist sehr cool.
Das war mein Lieblingsort,
als ich hier ein Praktikum machte.
Das sind ja Kakerlaken.
Schmeckt gut.
Das kenne ich schon,
schmeckt wie Chips. Super gut.
* Jazzige Klänge *
Am Vorabend seines Praktikums
verbrachte Alexandre
die erste Nacht in dem Zimmer,
das ihm sein Arbeitgeber
zur Verfügung stellt.
Aber er ist
gar nicht zufrieden damit.
Ich kann in diesem Loch
nicht weiter bleiben.
Ich suche mir jetzt ein Airbnb.
Schnell weg hier.
... rendre les cles.
C'est la fenetre ici, en fait.
Das ist schlecht fixiert,
es bewegt sich enorm
und die Kälte kommt rein.
Das Zimmer gefällt mir nicht,
das Bett ist zu klein für mich,
ich mag den Teppich nicht.
Es ist hässlich,
ich habe keinen Schrank.
Wenn ich entscheiden müsste zwischen
diesem Zimmer oder dem vom Campus,
würde ich ohne zu zögern
das vom Campus wählen,
auch wenn es klein war.
Wenigstens war das Bett okay.
Das Badezimmer war auch besser.
Und er ist kein Fan des Quartiers,
in dem er wohnt.
Das Paquis-Viertel -
man liebt es oder hasst es.
Ich mag auch diesen Ort hier nicht.
Ich habe schon so einiges Schlechtes
von meinen Freunden gehört,
was diese Gegend anbelangt.
Ich will hier nicht länger bleiben.
Heute beginnt mein Praktikum.
Ich weiss noch nicht,
was ich zu tun haben werde.
Ich werde jemanden
vom Personaldienst treffen,
dann werden wir sehen.
Vielleicht werde ich
heute Abend schon servieren.
Auch Alex beginnt sein Praktikum,
am Quai des Bergues.
Und da er sein Interview
per Videokonferenz geführt hat,
erkundet er zum ersten Mal
seine Umgebung.
Sehr hübsch.
Mein Bewerbungsgespräch
hatte über Skype stattgefunden.
Ich war soeben mit meiner
Housekeeping-Schicht fertig,
war noch im T-Shirt,
als ich eine Nachricht bekam.
Sie fragten mich, ob ich Zeit hätte.
Ich sagte Ja,
aber ich sei noch im T-Shirt.
Das sei egal.
Deshalb war ich noch nie hier.
Aber ich hatte ihnen gesagt,
dass ich hätte kommen können.
Er trifft an diesem Einführungstag
alle anderen neuen Praktikanten.
Ich freue mich, Sie heute
in unserer Firma zu begrüssen.
Ich weiss,
dass Sie alle ein Praktikum machen,
d.h.,
Sie studieren hier in der Schweiz.
Wir haben Leute von Glion
und von der EHL.
Nun zur Geschichte des Hotels.
(Mann) Wir haben das erste aus-
ländische Hotel in Japan eröffnet,
die erste Eisenbahnlinie in China
gebaut
und die erste einheimische Invest-
mentbank in Hong Kong eröffnet.
Alexandre holt seine Uniform ab,
im Bauch seines Hotel-Palastes.
Ich hole meine Uniform.
Ich arbeite hier.
Haben Sie schon eine Nummer?
Nein, überhaupt nicht,
das ist mein erster Tag.
Ah, Alexandre?
- Genau.
Das hier und ein Hemd.
- Ich habe nur ein Hemd zum Bügeln.
Eccolo! Bienvenu. Bonsoir.
In reglementkonformer Weste
und Krawatte trifft er
die Mitglieder seines Teams
für die Mahlzeit vor Dienstbeginn.
Alex und seine Praktikumskollegen
machen ein Puzzle,
um die Fassaden der Hotels
der weltweiten Kette kennenzulernen.
Das soll den Teamgeist fördern.
Ist das nicht in München? Ah, ich
habe gedacht, es sei eine Brasserie.
Das sind meine Augen,
ich habe es nicht erkannt.
Dann folgt
die Besichtigung der Zimmer.
Etwa 40 m2.
Jedes Zimmer ist gleich dekoriert.
Nur im sechsten Stock ist es etwas
anders, das zeige ich Ihnen später.
Ich hätte Lust,
mich hier hinzulegen.
* Heitere, verspielte Musik *
Sprung ins kalte Wasser
für Alexandre.
Er macht sich bereit,
seinen ersten Dienst anzutreten.
Begrüsst Alexandre,
unseren neuen Praktikanten!
Können Sie sich kurz vorstellen?
- Guten Tag an alle.
Ich bin Alexandre,
mein Vater ist Hotelier,
daher kenne ich
das internationale Milieu.
Ich habe
in zwölf verschiedenen Ländern
und elf Jahre in Paris gelebt,
bevor ich in die Schweiz kam.
Ich habe einige Praktika in meines
Vaters alter Hotelkette gemacht.
Ich war auch einige Male
in Paris im Service.
Ich bin jetzt an der EHL und
absolviere mein Praktikum bei Ihnen.
Heute Abend
werdet ihr in Zweierteams arbeiten,
also kein Stress,
ihr werdet noch informiert.
Habt ihr noch weitere Fragen?
(Mann) Für mich ist alles gut.
Merci.
- Bon service!
Die Teller polieren Sie mit Essig,
das entfernt die Flecken.
Sein erfahrener Praktikantenkollege
erklärt ihm
die vorbereitende Aufgabe des Abends:
dafür zu sorgen,
dass die Teller tadellos sind.
Schau, so macht man das.
Es muss alles sauber sein.
Ich mag die Atmosphäre
in diesem Restaurant,
das Team ist super
und sie verstehen Spass.
Das ist genau, was ich mag,
lachen zu können während Pausen.
Trotzdem sind alle fokussiert
und arbeiten gut. Das mag ich.
Wenn die Desserts kommen,
kann ich sie direkt servieren?
Das ist für Tisch Nummer 1.
Ja, du kannst gehen.
* Entspannte jazzige Klänge *
... eight, nine, ten,
eleven, twelve!
Das Ende naht,
es wird sicher schwierig.
Ich weiss nicht, ob ich es
schaffen werde, nicht zu weinen.
Aber ja, wir werden sehen.
Es macht mich schon traurig.
Die EHL, das ist wie eine Kolonie
für vier Jahre.
Vielleicht werde ich einige Leute
fünf oder zehn Jahre lang
nicht mehr sehen.
Aber ich weiss,
dass die Beziehungen,
die man an der EHL knüpft,
Freundschaften fürs Leben sind.
Was gibt es Schöneres,
um sich zu verabschieden,
als die Full Moon Party,
bevor man auf den harten Boden
der Realität zurückkehrt?
* Disco-Beats, Jubel *
Ihr Diplom mit Ehrenerwähnung
im Visier,
präsentiert Annina mit ihrem Team
am heutigen Vormittag
die letzte Version
ihrer Projektarbeit
am Zürcher Hauptsitz der Grossbank.
Wir präsentieren es in Zürich.
Es ist ein ungewohnter Rahmen,
deshalb sind alle etwas nervös.
Wenn ihre Recherchen
bestätigt werden,
können sie
das endgültige Konzept entwickeln.
Vor der Strategiedivision der Bank
präsentieren sie ihre Ideen,
um junge Kundschaft anzuziehen.
Als erstes möchten wir mit Ihnen
über die Notwendigkeit sprechen,
junge Leute
über das Thema Finanzen aufzuklären.
Dann würden wir gerne eine Reihe
von Möglichkeiten vorstellen.
Wir würden gerne die praktische
Umsetzung mit Ihnen diskutieren
und Ihre Meinung dazu hören.
Viele junge Leute
wählen das Paket der Kantonalbank,
weil sie
mit der Nachtschwärmer-Aktion
gratis die ÖV benutzen können.
Bieten Sie also dieser jungen
Kundschaft eine Hauptattraktion an,
steigt die Chance,
dass sie bei der Bank bleibt.
Sie überzeugen so sehr, dass sie zu
ihrer Überraschung eingeladen werden,
ihre Arbeit sogar der Direktion
der Grossbank vorzustellen.
Ich bin extrem positiv überrascht,
wie weit wir
bislang schon gekommen sind.
Sie haben einen super Job gemacht.
Wie sie auch als Team
zusammengearbeitet haben,
die Qualität ihrer Präsentation,
das ist auf einem Standard,
davon kann sich
noch manche Unternehmensberatung
eine Scheibe abschneiden.
Insofern ist es auch angemessen,
dass sie ihre Ergebnisse
präsentieren sollen.
Annina freut sich - auf ihre Weise.
Es ist speziell, wenn man weiss,
dass hochprofessionelle Leute
vor einem sitzen,
die schon viele Präsentationen
gesehen haben.
Man kommt als Student
mit drei Jahren Erfahrung.
Normalerweise präsentiert man
vor einem Klassenzimmer,
in dem die Hälfte schläft,
die Hälfte auf Facebook ist
und der Lehrer
ein paar Notizen schreibt.
Es ist ein ganz anderer Rahmen,
da viel mehr Expertise
und vermutlich auch viel mehr
kritisches Denken dahinterstecken.
Könnte sich Annina nach der Schule
auch eine Karriere
ausserhalb des Hotelmilieus
vorstellen, z.B. im Finanzwesen?
Vorerst sehe ich mich selbst
weniger im Bankbereich.
Momentan fehlt mir dort etwas
der menschliche Aspekt,
das ganze Zwischenmenschliche,
das in der Hotellerie
stark ausgeprägt ist.
Ein grosser Grund, warum ich die
Hotelfachschule in Lausanne mache,
ist auch, dass ich
den Menschenkontakt haben möchte.
* Verspielte elektronisch Klänge *
Adieu, Taumel, in Thailand,
bonjour, edle Karossen:
Afrim ackert am Autosalon.
Kann ich Ihnen behilflich sein?
Danke, wir haben alle nötigen
Informationen auf dem Tablet.
Wunderbar, sonst fragen Sie einfach.
Ich bin gerade von Thailand
zurückgekommen, es ist schwierig.
In Thailand war es sehr heiss
und hier ist es sehr kalt.
Der Unterschied ist enorm.
Momentan mache ich diesen Job, da
ich für den März noch keinen hatte.
Ich dachte, es wäre interessant,
ein bisschen hier zu arbeiten,
um aktiv zu bleiben,
Geld zu verdienen,
meine Rechnungen zu bezahlen,
das ist wichtig.
Bist du zum ersten Mal hier?
Ja, und auch zum letzten Mal.
Ich hoffe, einen Job zu finden.
Nein, drei hier, drei hier
und drei hier.
Momentan bin ich noch auf der Suche,
aber eher passiv.
Ich habe soeben
die Schule abgeschlossen.
Ich denke, ich werde im April
voll auf Jobsuche gehen
und Bewerbungen schreiben.
Ich mache mir keine grossen Sorgen.
Nächstes Mal in der Hotelfachschule:
Ich arbeite 7 Std. länger
als in Schweizer Praktika.
Ich musste sogar ein ärztliches
Zeugnis abgeben für 2 Std. Absenz.
Das ist nicht korrekt.
Es ist echt beschissen,
alle meine Freunde sind draussen,
während ich arbeite.
Es tut weh im Herzen.
Da stehen noch viele Ausländer.
In ein paar Minuten
sind sie alle Schweizer.
Das ist die letzte Chance.
Ich gelobe es.
Wenn ich auch nur
eine Prüfung versaue,
muss ich sie im Februar nachholen
und bin nicht mehr
mit meinen Kumpels zusammen.
Ich habe jetzt eine Stelle,
die ich annehmen darf
als Direktionsassistentin
und Human-Resources-Assistentin.
Zum Wohl!
- Zum Wohl!